in regards to the military could we
could we change topics specifically
to people who tried to hold the u.s
military complex accountable and what
happens to them
can we [ __ ] oh where am i who am i
talking about here
john f kennedy no yeah yeah sort of but
that's
the julio robert
julio
yes cassandra who's julian assange
julian assange
is possibly the biggest hero in the
world
in my opinion who should have a parade
and a day named after him but
no um he is the founder of wikileaks
also
so what's going on with julian assange
so i heard i heard trump was going to
pardon him i heard that too
yeah but that was that was bbs and it
was um
shocking news to his legal team and his
family and his friends
who were devastated a couple hours later
when
pastor mark burns tweeted that it was
fake news and that he had bogus sources
let me pull up the story we got from
newsweek is trump pardoning julian
assange pastor mark burns tweet sends
rumors flying
so i don't know if they have the tweet
pulled up but mark burns the verified
twitter user they don't
and he tweeted that uh that he was going
to
what did he say he wanted to say
disregard yeah i said breaking news they
don't have the tweet in this article
it's that's trash
but uh everybody kind of went nuts and
they all wanted to believe it
everybody wanted to happen left and
right i was in tears
but the left and the right the populists
left the papua's right were like this is
amazing trump should do this
the establishment was very angry oh bill
crystal
i remember sending out a message when
that happened i'm like okay we don't
know who the source is we don't know if
this is true we have no information that
verifies this but
let's keep this going because maybe
trump will see this and change his mind
didn't trump talk about it or he talked
about snowden i
i mean i got hundreds of messages right
after yeah i saw i saw your status
update you said uh journalists who
wouldn't spit on me if i was on fire
are now contacting me like crazy was
that what you said
yeah all these mainstream media
journalists are like hey cass
buddy ol pal what have you heard about
julian and i'm like oh are you guys
writing another hit piece on me or you
just want some info
you're gonna have to read gateway pundit
i was such a [ __ ] about this honey
sorry
um well so so so it's fake news huh
yeah um apparently i mean it's possible
that trump planted it so that he could
feel it out and see if there was support
which is why i was
encouraging people to to really tweet it
well the pastor had a photo of him
talking to trump in in what looked like
a confidential way that was his literal
picture
wait trump was talking to the pastor
there's a picture of the pastor
definitely it ties to trump
and trump said he was considering
pardoning everybody right literally
anybody who talks to him yeah so like
basically yeah
today uh julian assange's legal team put
in the official
formal request for a party i think it'll
happen you know why
why because trump wants to give a big
middle finger to the deep state
to the intelligence agencies who screwed
with them and jammed him up for years
but he still also has people like
neocons like grinnell and stuff
surrounding him being like
wikileaks is bad they're so bad they
hurt national security
right so i i i don't i don't i don't but
i don't know trump might be like
i'm going to burn it all down on the way
out i hope yeah i hope you're right but
if you look at trump's relationship with
wikileaks it's extremely bipolar it's
like you have a crazy girlfriend
that's like i love you i hate you i love
you i hate you if you remember trump
said
officially he loved wikileaks i love the
wikileaks
then when he became president he
pretended not to even know who julian
assange
was he talked about literally executing
chelsea manning
so when we're talking about his rights
about whistleblowers yeah and snowden he
talked about executing edward snowden
when we talk about his record on
whistleblowers it's not the best
i hope you're right you'll see but but
come on time is just
a sign if we're gonna do it do it stop
wasting everyone's time and stop raising
people's
false hopes about this let's do this
already julian assange is not a
whistleblower
he's a journalist correct that's it and
you can you can dislike
what he's published but i i i can't
remember who was talking about this but
it was like on fox news
and it was some republicans saying maybe
maybe one of the good ones
or something saying you know when the
new york times got the nsa
leaks were they charged and arrested
wikileaks gets information and they
publish it well this is the very
dangerous thing that's happening right
right now with julian assange if the
united states is able to get away with
this
anyone reporting anything anywhere in
the world regarded
regardless of their citizenship can be
arrested sent to the united states and
essentially sent away to jail for
telling the truth here's the best part
all of this basically confirms the
initial arrest of assange was bunk
yeah what was it the charge was like a
statutory rate split condom
right yeah literally yeah they tried
well they never actually charged him
they never charged him in that they they
imprisoned him for what seven years um
he was he was in the ecuadorian embassy
with asylum he was technically a
political refugee yes they were talking
about
secret grand jury indictments which the
mainstream media was saying was a
conspiracy theory yeah the mainstream
media
yeah the mainstream mirror is like
there's no secret grand jury indictment
against assange she should just leave
he's wasting
his time she's creating a spectacle the
mainstream media was literally on that
point like like white on rice and they
were
absolutely wrong yeah i believe it was
chief 2013.
um the stratfor league came out and they
laid out what they wanted to charge
julian with and an
espionage act was listed in there and i
would tweet about it all the time and
all these reporters would be like you're
such a conspiracy theorist he could walk
out of there any time he wants and i'm
like no he cannot and then what happened
door got kicked in and they dragged him
out during the trump administration
and there's wheeling and dealing behind
the trump administration with the
ecuadorian embassy with the united
kingdom to get him out of there and
that's exactly what they did so we have
to also
understand on the backdrop of trump
doing this to assange
is he going to pardon him but why did
trump do it to assange
well allegedly it's because assange
wouldn't give up his sources which he is
known for
for the sources of what he's still the
dnc manning
yes right yes so we have to we have to
hold on hold on what the source of what
the dnc leaks that's right if you look
at the big picture
it seems that trump was looking at
assange and he said i got the deep state
on my back accusing me of working with
russia
and they're claiming that that was used
to help me win and if assange just
said here's who was the actual source
was boom done russia gate gone overnight
yeah but russia gate's over it's been
done
people who were just paying attention or
had a pulse understand or
understood that it was bunk from the
very beginning why would he try to
appease the mainstream media to such a
point
why would he try to play up to the
mainstream media to such a point
to send an innocent man to jail no for
publishing information you don't get it
no i get what you're saying
regular people believe the media some of
them
do years they said trump was a russian
asset
of course i'm not denying that you're
totally right one guy went on msnbc and
says we must entertain the possibility
that donald trump has been working with
the russians since 1987. yeah that was a
soviet union
said that he was a russian agent yep as
he was banging
as he was witness it's crazy
it's absolutely and he was talking about
honey pasta as well saying that there
was russian honey pots
did you hear what they said on fox news
about swalwell and fang fang
no they were like when you're a two and
she's a ten
it's a honey pot hold on there's a baby
there's a babylon bee
article that is absolutely brilliant
with their headline today and
in in the headline reads chinese spy
assigned to date eric swalwell
begs to be sent to labor camp instead
and i'm like
that maybe happened you know it it's
probable but but again when we talk
about this whole russian collusion thing
if he's playing up to the mainstream
media so they don't call him a russian
asset what is he trading in for that
sending an
innocent male and sending a very i mean
cassandra what do you think about this
i mean i was a witness for the defense
in the
extradition hearings so i mean i
personally
testified kind of against trump
because i was given information that
donald trump personally ordered julian's
arrest
so i mean i'm personally not
overly confident that he's gonna do a
part in but i'm hopeful you know maybe
how how how is it that trump didn't
learn
and listen the media was was
spitting on him every single day and he
thinks they would ever give him a fair
shake
yeah he could have actually gotten
evidence that you know
about who the source was for the dnc
leaks and the media would just say it's
fake news
right they would say julian assange lies
and claims fake news but we know it's
russia
has never had to redact or apologize for
a story in history
they've never once published something
that was false retract
they do redact it retract right did i
say redact
i think so does it sound she said
retraction yeah you made a radowski both
but if you look at what what they're
accused of they're accused of
essentially what the new york times does
what the washington post does
every day all these websites use the
wikileaks model exactly for submitting
you know no no no you guys are wrong
wikileaks does not do what the new york
times does
the new york times is a propaganda arm
for the establishment wikileaks
publishes true information sorry what
the new york times
used to do no no no purports to do
okay do you guys remember back when the
palin emails went out on weekends oh
yeah
washington post set up a twitter account
that was still active last year when i
looked for it um
but they were they were calling for
volunteers to help go through palin's
emails
and then look at what they did with
clinton's emails look what they did with
hunter biden's emails yeah
but now they're all talking about it
because they want kamala yeah
yep kamala whatever
so in the beginning he released a bunch
of sensitive information
and then they charged him with statutory
rape is that right
okay i mean hold on on the surface
so basically he got
these cables from manning um
they got out or wikileaks was spending
about nine months
so far like redacting all these names
and making sure that nobody was gonna
get hurt because of it that they were
taking out locations of people who were
sensitive
or you know in afghanistan or whatever
but then lou cardin luke harding from
the guardian
released a book that had the password
and
a former wikileaks employee put out a
link
to the the full file unredacted
and so combined these two information
like these two pieces of information put
together led to
websites like cryptome and piratebay all
putting out the unredacted files and so
julian attempted to contact the state
department and be like hey guys
we have a problem uh we've been
redacting everything
but it's coming out and the state
department basically told them to screw
off
and so they ultimately ended up having
to release everything
but it leads to an interesting question
wikileaks wasn't actually the first to
publish the unredacted files
so how come the 50 other outlets that
published before
before wikileaks didn't get charged and
wikileaks did get charged why isn't luke
harding sitting in an embassy somewhere
so so there was a case in sweden
where the the government was basically
accusing him
of i think it was what a condom broke or
something yeah
a condom broke and there was a love
triangle and was having sex with an
underage woman
no no no no no there's never even been
an allegation of that
i guess they wanted to get him an sed
test that's what it was and so the
police were like
ah yes we're gonna arrest him for rape
and so he was one of her questioning
he said sweden has an extradition treaty
with the u.s and they're trying to get
me
so he went he was actually arrested
wasn't he he was arrested by british
authorities and put in a british
prison no well yeah but he went on he
was on house arrest
yeah yeah he was first he was arrested
he went to a british jail or prison
then they put him on house arrest with
an ankle monitor right and then he went
to the ecuadorian members arrested for
rape charges
no no he was never charged with never
but we have we have to understand
the american mainstream media ran with
headlines saying
julian assange is a rapist who's now
going to get americans killed all over
the world
rape a feminist organization even came
out and said that by calling
a condom breaking rape you are doing a
disservice to rape victims everywhere
but we have to understand there was many
mainstream media publications that ran
with that
and i remember being at the court
proceeding for chelsea manning
and it coming out that the leak didn't
like didn't lead to anyone dying but
that was the major thing that the
mainstream media was running with
the pentagon admitted that julian
assange i'll tell you what my opinion is
the whole swedish investigation was
dropped like the moment they snatched
him up and they're like okay we got him
okay we forget all that stuff we don't
care anymore
it was it was very obvious julian sounds
was right the whole time it was an
excuse
to get him to sweden they could send him
back to the us that was that was the big
plan they wanted to lock him down
lock him up they got him locked up in
ecuador embassy for years hindering his
ability to work
finally he gets pulled out by trump
julian assange was a thorn in the side
of the political establishment in the
deep state intelligence agencies
he was doing work as a journalist and he
was doing good work
and so they said well we can't have that
we own all the other journalists
you know i'm saying that figuratively
because they're all very much in the bag
i think most people who work for these
companies are activists who just love
the democrats and the establishment
thomas jefferson said that the um the
political parties will always maintain a
standing army of news writers
who will do whatever they want wishes so
julian assange they couldn't control
but pulled out as one term uh getting
him out of there and charging him and
now making him face charges is another
term so that's also another aspect that
we have done
because he is facing very serious
charges that could lead him to have
jail for the rest of his life 170 years
exactly espionage
charges trump better pardon this dude i
swear
look they're they're saying i'm gonna
clip that myself yes
dude i swear hold on hold on listen
donald trump
is facing criminal investigations at the
state level joe biden says he's not
going to go after him
so you know i was reading this thing
it's really fascinating from ulysses s
grant
he wrote about the civil war and he said
if anybody feels that they're oppressed
by the government it's their right to
revolution but you have to recognize
you're putting your life your property
and your
guarantees of citizenship on the line
when you do well they're basically
threatening trump supporters and trump
with that already kovitz taking away
people's property their life
their their their pursuit of happiness
and all that and so their their choices
are extremely
limited right now it's like what do i do
stand apart backward lose everything
donald trump is staring down the barrel
of these state-level criminal
investigations they're threatening his
life his property and his guarantee
his grant guarantees that his as a
citizen after all this goes down after
he
you know he leaves offices if that's
what happens so trump has every reason
to fight to the better end
but if trump loses support of people by
not making sure he abides by what the
actual populist right
and many on the populist left as much as
they might not like him if he just says
i'm going to close you up to the
establishment fine i won't pardon
assange
well then who's going to be supporting
him when he's a citizen
and they're going after him with these
with these with his crazy no one they'll
steamroll him and throw him under the
bus if he does that
and people are going to be like well a
lot of people support and and and and
respect
trump he needs to show the people that
he's going to stand up to the
establishment he needs to pardon people
like assange and snowden
and uh ross olbrich does that albright
russell bricked albrecht yep
he needs to he needs to tell that he
needs and i don't think necessarily
going to guarantee him more support he's
always going to have his base
but i think if he i would support him if
he did that if he pardoned
a freedom fighter yeah what if he
pardoned all non-violent drug offenders
who didn't plead down um i'm not too
concerned with all
or none things right now i just that's
too too complex
um there's just some people that need to
to not be charged
i think trump should rubber stamp the
part and just dishing him out like you
should make it rain particularly
i mean everybody likes to lump in julian
with all these other people particularly
snowden and i think that julian's
situation is much more dire
and it deserves to be discussed it's
like almost fraudulent the way they
went after the guy absolutely it was so
obvious to everybody
these these accusations against him the
smears in the media he was doing
real work publishing real journalism for
the first time in a long time
and you know what the powers that be are
like listen our friends you wonder how
it works
when you work for these news
organizations they're called access
journalists
they're like i better not make the cia
angry because they give me great scoops
and wikileaks embarrassed a lot of those
journalists
like it came out that they were you know
getting flipped stories from the dnc
that they were you know sliding over the
debate questions
uh to hillary clinton like they embark
wikileaks embarrassed the media just as
much as
embarrassed politicians yeah so if
donald trump sorry so no no no go right
here if donald trump
really wants to get back at these people
donald trump has spent four years
being like the fake news the fake news
we need real news if he
actually believed that and he actually
wanted to fight against fake news
and against the deep state that's been
going after him for four years
this is the best way to do it stick it
to them by showing them what real
journalism is and freeing julian assange
and and more than that a broad pardon to
protect julian
from other bunk bs charges very broad
preemptive
part yeah another thing that came out
that you just brought up was the fact
that the dnc wasn't just
directing the news but literally writing
the news
where mainstream media journalists sent
articles for approval
from the dnc and we're talking about
this is the mainstream media this is the
establishment many people had to resign
in disgrace because they got caught
red-handed just being puppeteers for the
establishment
not actual critical thinkers and
safeguards in the fourth branch of the
government they weren't any of that
they were puppeteers horse stream media
prostitutes that literally regurgitated
their talking points to the t
this is a bipartisan thing too you guys
were both at the dnc right yes
outside the dnc they were chanting
hillary cheats
thank you wikileaks yeah after bernie
conceded yep
and and that chant went on for a long
time and then they
they started taking away people's signs
because there were people who had
wikileaks signs
bernie signs dnc people came around with
the trash bags started throwing them all
away
they had white noise machines didn't
they yeah wow
but now now you have this new generation
of younger leftists
who don't like assange and don't know
anything about them well it's because
they don't they they don't
know they think politics started in 2017
or
whatever they're like orange man bad and
they don't remember
none of them had to bury their friends
like we did
after they like got shipped off to
afghanistan i mean i got mostly involved
in politics after my friend died in
afghanistan
and so when when wikileaks put out those
releases
the war logs i was like this is this is
it this is like
this is something that i will forever
support and stand for
but these people they they think that
politics just started
and they don't understand the trump is
bad we got to vote for biden he's just
an old man
it's like what was the war logs it
well it was 200 was collateral murder
part of it yes yeah
but it was it was a whole bunch of
cables and and
um documents that showed you know the
cost of war
essentially um it showed the u.s
government killed the reuters
well so and then they lied about it yeah
collateral murder was probably one of
the biggest releases
on youtube right yeah i was taken down a
lot it's a it's a it's a video showing
people walk out of a building
and then they just like kill them all
and it turns out it was like a reuters
journalist
not just them but also the ambulance
that came afterwards and they and they
shot up an ambulance with a small child
inside
yeah we also didn't really know how many
civilians were dying
or just how much death was happening in
general so
by releasing all these cables people in
america
got a chance to actually see what this
war was costing us
and what it was costing people all over
the world and
support because of wikileaks directly
support for the wars went down and
people started getting brought back
and so and the truth shall set you free
some other guy
released an unredacted report and julian
got busted for it
it's a little complicated but basically
the the files were being held online and
there was a
really encrypted password that you
needed to get to it but
um different news organizations that
were working with wikileaks all had this
password so they could all go
because there were so many files so they
partnered with like the guardian and all
these newspapers
they all had access to it but then luke
harding
wrote a book about wikileaks and he put
the passcode in the book
and the passcode had not changed and so
instead of being able to go through and
redact all these files
it all got put on piratebay and
kryptom.org
and all these websites and so julian it
was either you know pull the trigger or
yeah you know lose the story i still
remember this collateral murder video
because it was absolutely shocking to
finally see the true reality of what was
going on there and to see
helicopter pilots laugh and and and be
so inappropriate when it came to
executing what then we found out was
journalists
we also found out that reuters was
asking the us government what happened
what was going on here and the us
government just kept denying
the family members the journalists their
friends
their company they couldn't find
anything about what actually happened
how they
they died until this video came out
which
again just finally showed the american
people the reality of war because
we have to understand this iraq war was
a mainstream media war
it was squeegee cleaned it was there was
pr talking points there was there
was there was embedded news reporters
within the military showing you a
perspective of go america
it's great helping kids not the
perspective that we that the american
people saw in vietnam
where journalists actually saw and
reported on the realities of war which
made a lot of people anti-war in the
united states
we didn't have that but finally with
wikileaks we finally got the reporting
that we got during the vietnam war and
people started to finally ask questions
and saying
this is not protecting my freedoms these
guys with sandals in the middle of the
desert aren't a threat to me
and we have bloodthirsty psychopaths who
are literally foaming at the mouth
celebrating and are happy that they just
shot up innocent
that was people and journalists that was
the the video footage was from the bush
administration wasn't it
yes and then it carried on under the
obama administration
no matter what you feel about manning
too i remember during the trial
manning was like it was like watching
children torturing ants with a
magnifying glass
and i never forgot that it always stuck
with me
it reminds me of for what for
halliburton contracts yes
to to to gain strategic territory
surrounding iran because people like
john bolton want to celebrate
not even territory the iraq war made
iran
more powerful powerful and it and it
allowed them to expand their sphere of
influence in the region which makes them
a bigger threat against the u.s
geopolitical neocon power
so it didn't even serve the original
objective that they said it was serving
and it did the opposite of that
again order out of chaos creating more
problems which later on they're going to
have an excuse to solve which is
absolutely crazy i had a crazy idea
what if we just take the troops out of
these countries
whoa and bring them back here what right
well the ndaa this year
has come in no no
they're trying to pass a provision
within the ndaa that would prevent a
president
from sending troops back home okay so
hold on yeah the ndaa is the national
defense authorization yes
it's basically them approving the budget
and spending for all of this stuff when
it comes to war
and trump keeps saying he's going to
veto it and every time he does i just
laugh
and i just want to like put my feet up
and like crack a beer and be like do it
just do it i mean he's threatening to
repeal section 230 which is a big
mistake
but but i did didn't rand paul jam up
the ndaa
as well yes he did the whole filibuster
he always
and he's doing and he's and he's now
speaking out against it as well and he's
bringing up the fact that
you know under this ndaa a president has
unlimited power to send troops anywhere
in the world start any war he wants
lead people to death easily just with a
decree
but sending them home he can't now
without congressional approval
so that's in the new ndaa that they're
trying to get past
and these these uh this political
establishment
you know you know what it's like uh the
people in power right now i guess i was
describing it is like the neocons
slapped social justice as a rapping and
now they're
like democrats i guess it's the same
same thing the neocons and festival
parties they always have and you know as
soon as
as soon as uh the right started being a
little bit anti-war
you know bill crystal slithered over the
democrats
and was like hi guys hanging out from
his festering trash bag
wait you say you say slytherin what's it
what's it called when like slugs like
ooze their way what's it called sliming
their way
that's more you know yeah like you know
snakes are all right militants
rather than neocons these militants no
well but like
the point of the point i'm making is
neocons are a very specific group of
people they don't fight what i'm saying
is the difference
it's not conservative one is like
pro-social justice like it's not a
conservative thing to go to war that's a
very
it's not it's the opposition it's both
parties though these people have
infested both parties
i don't even think it's fair to say that
it's just
you know republicans or that all the
neocons have went over to the democrats
because it's not true
we still have dan crenshaw they have
bill crystal these people from pinak
all have spread out all over the place
and everybody just seems to forget all
the things that they've lobbied for and
the things that they've done but if you
if god forbid you tweeted 15 years ago
some kind of joke that's now perceived
racist they're not going to forget that
but if you lobbied for the iraq war and
lied us into war
you'll get elected president yeah you
can fit in with both parties they'll put
you on msnbc mitch mcconnell will say
players don't
vote for trump we need joe biden to win
so he can blow up more kids you guys
know who daniel ellsberg is
yes yes yeah he released the pentagon
papers which basically got us out of
vietnam
he's a big advocate of julian yeah well
also we just had the afghanistan papers
which were just released and again just
a blip
on the mainstream media and then never
really talked about again showed again
almost
exact similarities to uh you know the
vietnam
war when it specifically came to a
pointless endeavor that doesn't help
anyone
except for the military contractors with
even mainline u.s military officials
saying
there's absolutely no reason we're in
here but we still are this country
flourished best when there was an honest
well i shouldn't say there was an honest
press but when there were good
journalists doing the work
when there was a balance between the
government and the people and public
right to know
the weird things that luke brought up
like the heart attack gun we eventually
learn about these things because
journalists did their job
but these people thought it would just
be so easier
if the if the journalists were just in
our pockets if we just
we can we can feed them these stories
and they'll be too scared to speak out
against us
they'll support the establishment get
the activists in these organizations
and now there's none so there's no
challenge to a runaway broken system the
corrupt keep corrupting and the system
is decaying rapidly
because of it and independent media is
the only institution
still calling it out and that's why
we're seeing a lot of it being just
absolutely censored we won't exist
anymore
a lot of us if julian assange is thrown
in prison
i mean what kind of precedent is this
setting as soon as you know we have
some ultra left administration in there
they're going to toss all the right-wing
journalists in jail the right's going to
toss all the leftist journalists in jail
like
this this case sets up a horrifying
precedent people need to think about it
in terms
think about the opposite party
and if you would want the opposite party
having this people are bad at that
people are yeah they don't uh they don't
think beyond
what's happening now and i think one of
the issues too glenn greenwald brought
up an interesting point
that he said something like if there's
one group of people that has the
complete inability to learn
it's liberals who advocate for
censorship but i think what
you know what i was realizing when we
had some of these guests on who were
younger
and they're leftists a lot of these
people who are advocating for censorship
they they're young they didn't they
didn't go through uh
occupy wall street or the anti-war
protests so they didn't see the problems
caused by all of this
now they're like just entering politics
for the first time and they're all going
yay and cheering for the establishment
you know raising their fists in support
of the machine
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you